comme je vous aime beaucoup je vous
faire une interview cire pompes
[Applaudissements]
bonds est à venir pour vous êtes prêts
donc les robins vous êtes sans doute les
meilleurs comiques de votre génération
ouais
quel est le secret de ce feu d'artifice
dans le talent dont je dirais
génie génie
vous avez fait un parcours sans faute
jusqu'à maintenant une carrière
impeccable
vie sainte mois que pouvez vous espérer
de plus rien crever le plus vite
possible
comme james the way
est ce que vous êtes vraiment conscients
de votre charisme des fois je me demande
vous avez un charisme hors du commun oh
c'est un truc qui se sent tous les jours
dans la rue même chanson les gens vous
applaudissent dans la rue oui vous
faites les gens se mettent à croupir
celui-ci fait ce que j'avais à dire mais
sur mon passage et jean sakurai
s'accroupissent
vous est incroyablement désirable marina
oui
non mais c'est vrai comment faites-vous
pour résister aux sollicitations
masculine je ne résiste pas j'ai dit oui
à tout
et vous jean paul comment faites-vous
pour résister aux sollicitations
masculine d'un parent je résiste pas
devant vous en savez quelque chose qui
est riche
alors le tout paris bruisse de vos
exploits tous les deux ont dit que vous
êtes deux super coup marina c'est vrai
vous confirmez
je me démerde
j'ai un petit temple entre les jambes
vous faites comment pour être aussi
drôle tous les deux
de la crème hydratante way hydrate wii
est un logiciel être drôle à toute heure
qui d'honneur du l'intérêt qui sort de
la vingtaine il faut
alors les robinsons devenu pratiquement
indispensable aujourd'hui au paysage
audiovisuel français comment est ce
qu'on pourrait faire sans vous
ne pourrez pas s'il serait difficile
quoi ouais ça serait vraiment dites moi
vous avez ben hur et baffie aurait des
gens comme ça jamais
le bas du panier
on va
messieurs je vais score
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu